Hey, where at you?
I'm at that
dog shelter.
Lincoln, just
get a dog.
Ilana, I can't
inflict upon a dog
the crazy life
of a dentist.
Anyway, Abbi's not picking
up any of her calls,
so I'm pretty
sure she's dead.
I need you to be my
eyes and ears here.
Stay on the local news, they
only cover rapes and murders.
She didn't even say
"bye, Lincoln."
That takes
one more second.
People have no phone
etiquette these days.
Abbi!
Oh, my God.
What?
You wouldn't pick
up your phone.
I thought you
got SVU'd.
No, dude, I'm fine,
I just lost my phone.
Remember that hot
dude at the bar?
He was supposed to text me,
so now, I'm, like,
never gonna hear
from him again.
Oh, my God.
You should use
the FindMyPhone app.
I watch myself run around
the city all the time on it.
Oh, okay, well,
we'll just do that.
There's my phone,
I knew it was stolen.
Ugh.
Okay, it's in Harlem.
Great, let's go
track it down.
No, wait, wait, wait,
it's moving south.
It's in the
Upper East Side.
Oh, dude.
I-- I don't want
to go there.
Must we?
My son-in-law's
such a disgrace.
He went to Cornell.
I'm fine with the tsunami,
but not in St. Bart's.
Anywhere else
is fine.
It's the tenth horse
that died this year.
That's ten horses
I've had to replace.
Why does anybody
come up here?
It is a horrible,
vapid wasteland.
Um, excuse me,
where's the Met?
Oh, right down here,
you make a right.
Yeah, you can't
miss it.
Thank you.